[Music]
on this Wednesday night New Revelations
at the emergencies act inquiry testimony
about law enforcement leaking
information to protesters there was a
steady stream last two of the so-called
Freedom Convoy organizers take the stand
thousands honor a murdered RCMP officer
she helped everyone she could because
she had faith in them the regimental
funeral for Constable shailin yang
money and Medicine the pressure
provinces are facing to follow BC and
pay family doctors better and
cooperating for a cuddly creature to
feuding countries put aside their
differences for a panda in palliative
care
[Music]
the national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we are
getting a clearer picture of the
organization or lack of it during the
Convoy protest that occupied Ottawa for
weeks in February it ended after the
federal government invoked the
emergencies act and today at the inquiry
into the use of that act a lawyer for
some of the protesters testified that
information from the police was being
leaked to some of the people who
appeared to be leading the protest a
protest that was made up of a chaotic
mix of groups with a range of goals
including overthrowing the government
our chief political correspondent David
Aiken has our top story tonight
Edmonton's Keith Wilson would become
known as the Convoy lawyer representing
the non-profit Convoy organization as
well as a handful of their leaders it
includes
um Tamara Leach Chris Barber but Wilson
quickly found lots of other groups were
also on Parliament Hill to protest I was
sort of oh boy this is going to get
complicated Wilson testified his group
was helped by leaks from law enforcement
that helped protesters know what police
were up to there was a steady stream of
um of information and leaks coming from
all of the different police forces and
security agencies one controversial
protest leader getting that intel was
Pat King he took the witness stand
Wednesday where he was confronted with
this video Trudeau someone's gonna make
you catch a bullet one day that video
prompted other Convoy protesters to
denounce that comment a comment King
said he now regrets I'm absolutely
regret saying that I was mad but King
told the commission he was proud of his
work to lead the Convoy to Ottawa
finally the hard-working blue-collar
people of Canada were gonna stand up at
the time King and other protesters like
leader Tom arazzo believe there was a
way to replace the Trudeau government
without an election I'm willing to sit
at a table with the conservatives and
the NDP and the block as a coalition
I'll sit with the Governor General on
Wednesday though marazzo told the
commission he never meant he wanted
protesters to be part of the government
and I wanted them to come and sit
literally at a table and start figuring
out a way
to
Be an Effective opposition in fact
morazo testified there may have been no
Convoy had the conservatives done a
better job opposing the Trudeau
government's vaccine mandates of course
the conservative leader at the time
Aaron O'Toole would be deposed by his
own party partly over the Convoy to be
replaced by Pierre poliev and pauliev
made a point at the time of supporting
the goals and objectives of Freedom
Convoy 2022 David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
an RCMP officer was remembered today for
her extraordinary and unwavering faith
in humanity thousands of police and
First Responders from across Canada and
from the U.S gathered in BC to pay their
respects to Fallen officer Shaylin yang
[Music]
the sound of bagpipes and drums they
paid tribute to a colleague the Burnaby
RCMP officer a member of the mental
health and Outreach team was stabbed to
death last month a parade of color
including a sea of red surge took part
in the regimental funeral to honor her
the service was held in the community
the Constable loved and where she lived
nitu garcha reports
sorrow and sadness over the tragic loss
of one of their own
the death of 31 year old Constable Shay
Lin Yang prompting an international
outpouring of support and condolences
relatives of service members from across
the region lining the procession route
it's very hard and I think as Canada
it's important we come together pay our
respects for this young lady
a couple of shifts so he got to know her
a little bit Yang worked as a homeless
and mental health Outreach officer with
Burnaby RCMP she was fatally stabbed
while helping to serve an eviction
notice on a man living in a tent in a
local park 37 year old John Wan ham
charged with first-degree murder in
Yang's death remains in custody his
hearing has been adjourned to a later
date after he appeared via video in a
Vancouver courtroom Wednesday while the
service for Yang was underway
inside the packed Richmond Olympic Oval
tributes were paid on behalf of Yang's
family and friends she was loving yet
firm and treated everyone the same my
friend shines so brightly and truly had
an impact on everyone around her she was
the daughter of immigrants from Taiwan
where her father flew from to attend the
regimental funeral her upbringing and
Community involvement helped guide her
to become the gentle yet Brave
empowering and courageous individual
whose life mission was to help others
she made us better
and stronger describing her last call as
one answered with unflinching bravery
everything she did was defined by her
empathy
her compassion and her belief that she
could change the world relatives and
colleagues highlighting how her death is
a stark reminder of the dangers all
officers face in the line of duty and
that Yang's Legacy will always live on
Global News Richmond BC
taming inflation and averting a
recession prompted the Central Bank in
the United States to raise interest
rates there for a sixth time this year
the U.S federal reserve hiked its rate
by another 75 basis points to a target
range of 3.75 to 4 percent that's the
highest it's been since January 2008 and
it's a big jump from the first increase
in March this year when the range was
around 0.25 to 0.50 percent inflation
and interest rates are on the minds of
Canadians too and tomorrow the federal
government is hoping to reduce some of
the worry when it delivers its fall
fiscal update experts though are not
predicting great news as Canadians
struggle to pay their bills Abigail
Beeman reports
so I got two for a dollar 46. Greg
wetton is driven by deals another Dairy
price hike approved for February will
affect his family with a little one who
goes through a lot of it our friends
have kids they know about this too and
they're like have you loaded up on the
yoga
we all know Canadians are fed up with
inflation when I go to pay I often in
shock to see what there's no change
being affected and the the regular basic
Canadian is getting
kind of sorry screwed Thursday the
federal government presents its fall
economic update not a budget but it can
set the stage for the Springs I think
this is where the government has an
opportunity to kind of say okay we hear
you we know there are vulnerable
Canadians
if things get worse you know we might
have you know certain measures
um available by budget time that could
address some of these pressures the
backdrop many economists predict a
looming our word we're forecasting
recession in the first half of 2023 but
don't expect the fiscal update to wield
that blaring headline careful not to
make anxieties worse you never want to
see that a recession is coming uh that
in itself can become a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you have the government
that's ringing the alarm bell saying
we're doom and gloom uh that translates
into anxiety of course Canadians are
anxious but the good news is the deficit
has been shrinking they have to try to
find that balance of being shown to
provide support and providing support to
Kent the most vulnerable Canadians but
at the same time not exacerbating uh the
inflation Minister Freeland has always
shown a sensitivity to where the sweet
spot is and I expect Festival to find
out in the full economics this is an
opportunity for the government to Signal
maybe a change introductory for the
first time in a long time that says
there going to start to moderate the
rate of growth and spending of course
potential Cuts involve Politics as well
as policy and the Trudeau Liberals are
no longer fresh with an eye on the next
election Khan says for third-term
government's hope isn't enough Canadians
want results-oriented spending and
outcomes Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
tensions are running high on the Korean
Peninsula after North Korea launched its
largest ever barrage of ballistic
missiles
23 missiles were launched setting off
air raid warnings on a South Korean
Island residents there were told to rush
to underground shelters all of the
missiles did land in the sea but the
launches are widely seen and condemned
as an escalation of hostilities by the
North in response South Korean war
planes fired air-to-ground missiles
North into the sea across the disputed
Maritime border
three days after 156 people were crushed
in a crowd in South Korea investigators
have raided police stations across the
capital Seoul
the raids came a day after the agency
acknowledged Soul police failed to act
for hours despite receiving at least 11
emergency calls from pedestrians
concerned about the overcrowding the
deadly Crush happened Saturday night
during South Korea's Halloween
festivities
to the war in Ukraine now Russia has
abruptly reversed its decision to pull
out of a U.N broker deal that ensured
vital grain exports can safely leave
Ukraine's ports on Saturday Russia
suspended its participation accusing
Ukraine of a drone strike on its Black
Sea naval fleet now Moscow says it has
received kiev's written guarantees the
safe passage Corridor will not be used
for military purposes
Poland's government has approved plans
to construct a razor wire fence on its
border with the Russian city of
kaliningrad Poland's defense minister
announced the 210 kilometer long project
over concerns the Russian Enclave could
become a channel for migrants Poland
built a similar barrier last fall when
thousands of African and Middle Eastern
migrants tried to cross the border from
Belarus into Poland
a remedy that requires an overhaul
coming up the push to better compensate
family doctors across Canada
foreign
[Music]
ER and his ministers stop lying about
the damage they're doing to the
education system Mr tabins you are named
you must leave the chamber for the day
considered unparliamentary and so a
fiery question period in the Ontario
legislature ended with the NDP leader
and 15 mpps being ejected the NDP are
upset about legislation that would
prevent education workers from striking
the government of Doug Ford has
introduced it ahead of a planned walkout
on Friday by QP education staff and this
NDP says it's an attack on workers
constitutional rights unless there's
some progress at the bargaining table
most Ontario students will be out of
school starting Friday
British Columbia is taking steps to
address the ongoing shortage of family
doctors in this country the province is
bringing in groundbreaking new payment
models that will make Family Physicians
there among the highest paid in Canada
and as Jamie Maraca explains that could
put pressure on other provinces to
follow suit
after 30 years Dr Ava grunfeld has no
plans to practice Family Medicine
outside of Ontario but she worries those
starting out might it's taking from
Peter to pay Paul
um so you know if we take a national
perspective it's not the solution to the
problem Canada is facing a Countrywide
family doctor shortage this week BC
announced it will treat the crisis by
moving from the fee for service model
where Physicians earn around 30 to 40
dollars per visit no matter the
complexity of the patient's problem to
one based on time spent with patients
earning qualifying Physicians an average
annual salary increase from two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars to more than
385 thousand dollars in contrast the
latest data shows GPS in Ontario
Canada's most populous Province made an
average of 360
000 in 2019 2020 the best agreement
negotiated for physicians in Canada this
year exciting for BC doctors and
patients says the president of the
Canadian Medical Association patients
want time with their physician they want
that time to have impact and they want
their problem to be solved when they
walk on at that door provinces that
aren't competitive risk losing valuable
staff Nova Scotia which has seen the
need for family doctors more than double
over the pandemic has some of the lowest
pay in the country still when asked the
health ministry didn't commit to higher
salaries neither did Ontario Alberta
doctors are among the top earners still
the official opposition expressed worry
over its neighbors pay bump I truly fear
that Alberta doctors will look to BC BC
May entice them in the short term but to
be sustainable Dr grenfeld says
ultimately there needs to be a shift in
how the profession is perceived salary
is one thing
reputational
position and attitude is another thing
you know we're in the hierarchy of of
medicine do you just want to sit and the
third is the quality of like long-term
problems that will need to be triaged
Jamie Morocco Global News
reporting Latino voters in the U.S ahead
what Democrats and Republicans are doing
to motivate them
Israel held its fifth election in four
years and although the final results
aren't expected for a few more days
former prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
has taken an early lead
[Applause]
reporters on Tuesday night Netanyahu was
ousted by a coalition of his opponents
and now to form a new government he will
need to form a coalition of his own
including with a party known as
religious Zionism whose leader was once
a part of a group labeled a terrorist
organization by the U.S the partnership
would create Israel's most far-right
government in its history
the American president facing the
possibility of losing control of the
Senate and the House of Representatives
is raising the stakes for next week's
midterm elections Joe Biden was in
Florida last night making the case that
the election is not a referendum on him
but a choice between extreme Mega
Republicans and Democrats
this election is not a referendum
it's a choice it's a choice
between two vastly different Visions for
America this is really deadly Earnest
man
democracy is on the ballot this year
millions of Americans believe the lie
that the 2020 presidential election was
stolen from Donald Trump and more than
300 Republican candidates for the
midterms believe it too or at least say
they do election deniers and lies about
voter fraud or part of the mainstream
now with so much at stake there's an
urgent Push by democrats to engage
millions of Voters in key Battleground
States especially Latinos who make up
the largest fastest growing part of the
electric Jackson prosco went to Orlando
Florida to see the effort to get out the
vote
in Orlando volunteers visit Latino
households making sure every eligible
voter is registered and ready for
election day we have to invest more time
in educated our new borders the people
that come into United States and become
a citizen
Chief me Familia Vota Works to engage
Hispanic voters including new citizens
who know what's at Stake
Executive Director Soraya Marquez is
originally from Venezuela so we lost the
Democracy in our country and the dream
that we have in the United States is
exercise the right to bodies since the
last midterms in 2018 the number of
registered Latino voters in the U.S has
increased by 5 million as a Hispanic
Community or Hispanics we should get out
there and vote you want changes you have
to to both don't go up by what they've
seen on TV experts warn politicians
continue to miss the mark in courting
this large and important demographic
It's Like Satellites that circulate our
communities every two or four years we
don't see them until it's election time
the biggest mistake assuming Latino
voters will vote as a block supporting
only one party we're a very diverse
complex
non-monolithic uh group of people a
recent poll of Latino Americans found
the biggest concerns are inflation crime
and immigration where a strong majority
opposed the decision by Republican
Governors to fly and bus migrants to
democrat-led communities when you take
it to the point of you know playing
games with them putting them in buses
promising wonderful things in New York
and and elsewhere
I think that has backfired at the same
time Democrats have been weighed down by
the unpopularity of President Joe Biden
and the overall state of the economy
I've noticed a drop in engagement uh in
the Latino Community it's sort of like a
disengagement if you would back in the
community the biggest fear is many
Latino voters will simply stay home out
of frustration giving up their voice in
elections where every vote matters if we
vote in every single election we are
contributing to make
democracy is stronger in the United
States and even in Freedom Jackson
prosco global news Orlando
we'll have full coverage next week from
Washington D.C As Americans head to the
polls I will be live from the capitol
looking at the many factors influencing
the selection
Panda diplomacy next a sick animal
creates a rare chance for cooperation
[Music]
just about every story about China and
Taiwan these days is about tensions
escalating Taiwan insists it is
independent China has never accepted
that and Views Taiwan as part of its
territory well this week a new character
entered the equation a panda a panda who
is sick and as Mike Armstrong explains
that has led to a rare moment of
cooperation
the Taipei Zoo has four giant pandas
three are in enclosures for the public
to watch and one is in palliative care
twantuan turned 18 in August and was
diagnosed a month later with a suspected
malignant brain tumor zoo is now trying
to determine whether a delicate surgery
could help and to make that
determination their undergoing a
delicate geopolitical procedure
the zoo says they've brought together
experts from both sides of the Taiwan
Strait pooling Taiwan and China's
knowledge and strength
Taiwan and China don't usually talk much
less cooperate on much diplomatic
relations were cut off in 2016 and
tensions have ratcheted higher and
higher in recent years
Chinese leader Xi Jinping promised last
month Taiwan would be reunified with
China if necessary through Force
while Taiwanese officials have boosted
military spending and promise to be
ready for a fight
two sides appear to have put the saber
rattling on hold to help tuantuan two
penned experts from China arrived in
Taiwan Tuesday the pair works at China's
main Panda Research Center
the zoo says its vets and the Chinese
experts Wednesday examined juantuan
together they say his eating and
digestion are steady but the location of
the tumor makes surgery too dangerous
for now and they're nervous about how
he'd react to Anesthesia no the
dependent might help ease tensions
likely shouldn't be a big surprise
they've been a tool of Chinese diplomacy
for more than 80 years two were sent to
Cotter just last month they're leased to
other countries and that's supposed to
encourage ties while Tuan Tuan may be
doing just that the Chinese team is
supposed to stay in Taiwan for a week
Mike Armstrong Global News
that's global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna freeze and no pandas
for tonight's your Canada but we do have
this Trio of beavers relaxing in
Saskatoon thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you